marachi l'adjoint du shérif toi tu vas
bien qu'est ce qui s'est passé évanoui
d'accord je recommence je m'appelle lara
jean
avant j'étais totalement invisible
personne ne faisait attention à ce que
je faisais j'écris une lettre chaque
fois que j'ai un coup de coeur si
intense que je sais pas quoi faire
d'autre
j'en ai écrit pour cinq garçons filter
et ses beaux yeux
kenny du camp de vacances lucas du bal
de l'école john du club de modélisation
de l'onudc et josh le garçon d'à côté
et on peut savoir ce que tu fais rien du
tout personne ne connaît leur existence
tu peux peut-être admettre qu'à une
partie du toit qui aimeraient que toute
ta vie ne soit pas qu'une fiction
il est temps que tu montres à tout le
monde qui tu es vraiment
lara jean bienvenue à ma fête
le cache pas c'est deux parties toile
accord g
[Musique]
tipi rôle à moi
je suis partante
horaire est ce que je peux te parler à
moi ouais alors voilà sache que ça me
touche mais ça n'arrivera jamais je te
demande pardon je trouve ça super cool
puis je pense que j'ai des petites
taches d'or dans les yeux seulement toi
merde
les lettres ont été envoyées